bienvenue sur diagonale tv donc
poursuivre la suite de ce championnat du
monde
2016 entre donc le tenant le champion du
monde en titre
l'extraordinaire norvégien magnus
carlsen est donc son challenger le russe
sergueï kaliakine alors carrière qui n'a
de nouveau les blancs dans cette
septième partie alors qu'il avait des
bleus déjà aussi dehors de la 6ème
pourquoi puisque le match à 12 parties
et donc en fait en milieu de match après
donc la sixième
il ya inversion des couleurs c'est à
dire que donc carson avait démarré avec
les blancs cariat qui n'avait fini
lui-même avec les blancs la première
partie du match et maintenant c'est les
verts scarlets qui ne démarre avec les
blancs et donc c'est que larsen qui
finira avec les blancs le match voilà
donc ceci étant expliqué on va voir ce
que va jouer à 6h15 à quinet ce qu'on va
avoir deux nouveaux droits à une
espagnole que carsen a magnifiquement
joué jusqu'à présent sans subir
véritablement de problème pour l'instant
que la rai qui n'arrivent pas à poser
problème car scène alors que personne
n'est passé passé loin n'est pas passé
loin comme on a pu le voir un de marquer
un premier point mais pour l'instant
c'est toujours match nul kaya qui ne
démarre avec attention suspense boom à
des quatre donc variations car est il
financé un peu un aveu de faiblesse
kara qu'il n'a pas à trouver
finalement comment déborder carsen sur
sur l'espagnol il s'est senti un peu
dépassée peut-être donc il sait varier
donc c'est peut-être un premier signe là
sa dans le match puisque jusqu'ici
suivez la stratégie russe de d'insister
sur la même ouverture carsen répond on
parle des 5 c 4 6,6 donc là on va avoir
droit très certainement à avec cette
structure ici de défense ici c6 est ce
qu'on appelle la slave alors la slave
c'est très solide notamment envoyé sur
les cases blanches parfois même on joue
à six après on va le voir
le problème c'est le développement de ce
fou parce qu'évidemment de plus il ya
deux pions soucasse blanche
ici plus ce fou a du mal à trouver une
bonne case mais on verra ça plus tard
pour l'instant on continue calais c3
khalip 6e 3 voilà tranquillou donc
finalement là on ne pourrait peut-être
sans doute aussi jouer fou g5 ici mais
bon 3 et tout
on protège ces quatre cas de prison peut
reprendre pas de risque pas de risque
positionnelle ici dans cette ce début
d'ouverture ici à 6 par la typique on
l'a dit tout à l'heure à 6 typique de
cette défense là
l'idée c'est qu'après les échanges ici
bon ben on peut jouer b5 et en plus on
jouera ensuite ces 5
on a envie de jouer le pion aux six ans
et scène pour s'échanger contre le tour
des quatre plus tard d'un jour à 6 on
évite des pénétrations sur la classe b 5
soit un fou un échec ici ils sont un
cavalier et en même temps près par b 5
avec le fou qui à la fin aura finalement
ça y est trouvé sa bonne kazan bessette
avec une magnifique diagonale ici une
fois que ce sera échangée pense assez
bouché mais ça va s'ouvrir très vite
c'est ce qu'un peu ce qui va se passer
d'ailleurs ou d3 puis on prend ces
quatre et voyez que c'est des gones elle
commence à s'éclaircir on a enlevé un
pion du centre pour entreprendre un pion
de côté l'avantagent des blancs par
contre c'est qu'on a deux pions ici
contre voilà centralement au niveau du
centre donc la masse de pions blanche et
plus est plus importante que celle des
purs noir sur les deux colonnes centrale
prend 2,6 logique donc le 6 logique
puisque qu'on l'a dit on veut peut-être
joué ces cinq baies -celles donc ça va
libérer la classe b 7 pour le fou donc
on n'a pas peur de jouer aussi ce avant
d'avoir sorti se fout de ce côté là
parce qu'on veut sortir de l'autre côté
n'est pas vraiment boucher puisque c'est
facile à sortir
qui plus est bien entendu l'idée de 6
est très simple c'est une idée de
développement
ce faux et fuite va sortir soir 7 soit
parfois en bep cap pour clouer le
cavalier ou en d6 aussi en contrôlant la
classe de cinq et on prépare bien
entendu petit rock puisque comme on a
bougé les pions de belles dames on va
par ok du côté où on a avancé ses pions
cabinet 3c 5 voilà tout de suite précis
souci on joue d'abord forcé depuis ces 5
en cas de prise on aura joué deux fois
le fou là si les blancs prennent et bien
sûr le fou en même temps on gagne du
temps donc on joue ces 5 avant de jouer
le fou pour savoir un peu ce que font
les blancs et décider soit de prendre
des quatre nous-mêmes et sortir le fois
pris soin de deux passions de tuer tout
simplement petit roquet
ben voilà c'est leur voile a cédé bonal
voyez ça c'est magique parce que les
noirs au début mais tous leurs pions sur
blanc et finalement quelques coups plus
tard ils ont tous se libérer sept 7
qu'en diagonale voilà je trouve ça c'est
assez joli comme manoeuvre en bouche une
diagonale pour la libérer après les cinq
attaques le fou fou deux très bien il
faut ouvrir la maison sans doute aussi
les blancs ici prévoit de contrer le
foot 17 par un fief 3 ultérieure on va
donc bouger ce cavalli soit 1,5 soit en
d2 soit au run je sais pas plus tard et
ensuite fait froid et le fou noir quand
même qu'il très puissant sur cette trêve
hivernale soit tout simplement échangé
par le fou son collègue adverse de cases
blanches et donc ça neutralisera sa
puissance ou 17 puis on prend c'est
celle donc les blancs voyez ici se
décident eux-mêmes apprend dans ces
cercles voyez c'est là qu'on voit que le
coût des noirs est très bien joué de
jouer ces 5 et de patienter avant de
sortir leur fout puisque les blancs là
n'avaient pas n'ont pas trouvé d'autres
coûts plus actif que de prendre
eux-mêmes l'on perd pas de temps avec le
fou on n'a pas d'abord jouer puis
ensuite de voir reprendre en deux temps
voilà un seul temps pouf pas tout de
suite le ring avec ses 6 mais pas tout
de suite voilà c'est le coup un peu rare
sur ce coup-là mollahs on aurait pu
prendre dans ces scènes tout de suite
sans doute un sans problème la carcel
joue un coup bon cavalier sait si ce
n'est pas pressée de reprendre c'est
cela les blancs ne peut vrai faire pour
protéger un des quatre étapes haussier
le clos de carli prend donc c'est vrai
que bon pourquoi pas jouer car ici tout
de suite
enfin beaucoup bien sûr un peu rare donc
peut-être surprend un peu car yakine
aussi la caisse qui fait parce que c'est
pas facile si je jouais 4 pour sortir
mon fou bon ben j'ai fait bien pire le
pian b4 le cas les bouger le pion
quatrième prise ne sais pas ça va pas si
j'oublie et trois bombes et c'est le
plus petit bras pour mettre le front de
b2 mais bon petit bras au sens où bombay
a pris l'espace côté dames on mettrait
le fou sur une belle diagonale aussi
mais position symétrique en termes
structure de pions il semblerait déjà
bon là
y a pas de pas de grands avantages pour
les blancs ici tout de suite donc
simplement alors il joue cavalier des
deux car avec in or l'idée de calais d2b
c'est un peu ce qu'on a dit tout à
l'heure
double alors mettre un x f3 pour contrer
ce fou 17 est aussi visé la case 4 voilà
je veux car les kin sans doute mettre un
cavalier en quatre il y en a deux c'est
bien si on a deux quand on en prend 1
l'autre revient et c'est vrai que c'est
une belle case attention aussi en venant
aux quatre on protégerait le pion c5
donc les noirs ont pas intérêt
maintenant à laisser le pion ces cinq
ans prise trop longtemps et une fois
qu'on a dit ça vous comprenez tout tout
de suite le coup pour chiens de carsen
très simple forcément voilà ans essec
il n'attend pas que les blogs jouer
socali b3 soit 4,4 pour protéger ce pion
et avec des problèmes pour le récupérer
non le prend tout de suite c'est fini
regardez les noirs en sorties toutes
leurs pièces montrent plus que le rock à
faire pas de danger sur leur en noir
dont plus rock et on peut même patienter
un peu pour le faire de toute façon est
bon les blancs un structure de pions
symétrique voyez les quatre pions là les
caps sont là deux pions contre 2 pioro
c'est difficile de dire là que les
blancs ont obtenu grand-chose de
l'ouverture mais bon la partie continue
bien sûr c'est une partie équilibrée
pour l'instant cavalier 4 voilà donc on
avait dix ont visé aussi la case de cas
tout en permettant de venir aussi en f3
avec le fou on attaque ici attention
mais sur le fond ses cinq fautes et noir
réagissent donc d'abord un échange
maintenant de nouveau le foot attaqué
puisqu'on a remplacé le cavalier voyez
un doublement de cavaliers là le fou va
bouger très certainement en eux cette
voie là tranquillement retour à la
maison position calme équilibré
structure de pions symétrique
voilà 4 2 contre deux allèles dames
quatre contre quatre les droits des
positions des pions bien en face
symétrique c'est un facteur annulant
très fort car scène pas de problème dans
cette ouverture il pas débordé du tout
cariat qui n'arrive toujours pas à les
poser de problèmes sérieux là un coup
petit bras la boe mais coiffe quoi faire
aussi peut-être pas autre chose mon b 3
c'est un bon coup bien sûr mais sans
plus voilà bon coup quoi parce que se
fout pas pareil que l'autre c'est à dire
que voilà il bloqué par trois l'autre
était bloqué par six on va le mettre en
b2 mais bon ça veut dire que vous voyez
la position est symétrique même
emplacement de pièces la seule
différence c'est le câble et ses 6 à la
fin imaginer qu'on mette le four b2 tout
est pareil sauf le cray valley sait si
c'est le cas les eaux 4 ou en mission il
ya six baies 5 aussi fait bouger un peu
plus loin que à deux baies 3 eh ben on
n'a vraiment pas grand chose à la
symétrie est quasi totale là donc très
joli coup car c'est ni si cavale et b4
ça c'est bien superbe calais b 4 très
actif il repart briller il a pas ok le
fou contre le cas le cavalier donc ça
c'est un premier point jusqu'à vider pas
en l'air je fais beaucoup trop loin donc
ici lecavalier n'est pas en l'air bien
sûr le fou attention attaque 4 qu'il
faut faire quelque chose
c'est un coup actifs et petite pression
sur à deux bombes et ça veut dire que la
tour 1 devra rester dans le coin
je pourrais peut-être plus tard aussi
peut-être fonds m6 qui attaquent la tour
si la tour de justement doit bouger de
votre problème petite pression de ce
cavalier
si les blancs jouent à trois ils
affaiblissent un peu leurs pions si on
les avances les pions ils
s'affaiblissent un peu peuvent devenir
des cibles pour en tout cas plus on
avance plus c'est facile les attaques et
s'ils sont loin mais non c'est plus dur
voilà un coup actifs tranquillou bombes
et les noirs mettent eux aussi
finalement un cavalier sur la quatrième
en jeu adverse tandis que ce cavalier ou
4 étaient bien alors sur la quatrième
rangée des blancs donc voilà il ya un
peu plus actif calais b 4 en termes d'
attaque donc au cou dynamique là on
recoupe pas tout de suite et on place
une pièce en position agressive
voilà c'est bien joué joli coup fo est
roi voilà bonne idée
bien sûr la même l'idée de base de
calais des deux ailes et la foule est
roi on l'a vu la case 4 nickel le plan
tranquillou sergueï kaliakine très
classique très sérieux propre
la position n'a pas de problème pour les
blancs n'ont plus cessé joli coin c'est
un beau développement harmonieux des
deux côtés petit rock fois trois
superbes ce que j'aime beaucoup ce coup
on rend dans une passe tactique là on va
voir sa vie non scouts on peut venir
aussi en b2 qu'on l'a vu tout à l'heure
en b2 ont visé d'attaqué peut-être la
casse g7 et le roi derrière moment là
pourquoi pas mais x 3 cc vicieux parce
que voilà il peut se passer des trucs là
à noter aussi que même avant x 3 ici les
blancs auraient pu faire cavalier chèque
le roi est attaqué on prend du fouet le
fou 17 et en prison voilà le problème de
ça c'est quand on a repris du fou et 6
il ya la tour 1 qui est en prise et si
on reprend bessette dans le premier set
et le fou ici n'est pas sera pas en
prison va le voir tout de suite parce
que c'est un peu l'idée de la suite de
la partie donc x 3 maintenant la dame
aussi protège la tour voyez dans le
début de vente que je vous ai un peu au
signifié on va le voir à tout de suite
on va le voir ici là on regarde et on
attaque donc attention cavalli b4
fawcett et à tous réfutent derrière ici
attention ce fou et attaque le foot 17
qui est en l'air au sens non défendu
donc ça veut dire un cavalier échec et
on peut
prendre le fou ou une cabale et bouge
peu on pourrait créer une autre menace
il ya que cali échec comme menace c'est
le genre de découverte qu'il faut
calculer avec précision quand on rentre
comme ça dans des positions où il ya un
peu de tactique comme ça il peut se
passer des idées des menaces sur des
pièces dans défendu donc il faut faire
très attention restez très entendu
attentifs comme ça vous avez des pièces
non défendu avec des découvertes en
phase qui pourrait l'attaqué des coûts
intermédiaires il faut rentrer dans le
calcul précis les noirs jouent dans ces
huit voix là pas de problème
personne n'a pas peur menace potentielle
aussi attention cavale et ses 2 pour
attaquer la torah est bon il faut faire
attention le fou pétrole fois trois
prêtres attaqué aussi dans ces huit
m'ont beaucoup cavaliers f6 échec mois
la carrière qui ne rentrent ici dans la
variante qu'on avait esquissé il profite
regardez du vis-à-vis la foule f3 fou
bessette vous décédez pas défendu et il
rentre dans une phase tactique voile et
vous allez voir calcul russe très fort
camille échec donc là il n'a pas le
choix on pas bougé le roi ben sinon il
faut prendre 17 et on a on perd du
matériel faut prendre si on prend du
plomb fou prend bessette et les blancs
davantage pourquoi parce que le roi sera
un peu dégarni tomber cette attaque la
tour c au moment de jouer
petit avantage blanc à cause de fête que
le rock et affaiblisse pas décisif mais
quand même non négligeable donc arsène
reprend du fou et donc ça attaque la
tour mais comme on l'a vu le foie trois
attaques lecavalier la tour la caisse
qui suit d'abord vous prendre 17 ans la
prise prise donc il ya eu échange de
pièces la tour c 8 est attaqué le calais
b 4 est attaquée mais les noirs aussi
atteint 14 lato ici
généralement il faut prendre le maximum
de matériel dans ce type 2 2 passes
tactique passe d'armes fou prend un tour
donc là les noirs en prime tour font
reprendre une tour aussi d'en avoir un
problème on a le choix maintenant soit
on prend la tour c 8 directement soit
plus malins on prend le fou voilà pour
le cavalier pourquoi parce que la tour
et s'attaquer le fou à est attaqué et la
deuxième tour est attaqué aussi parce
que voilà donc les noirs peuvent pas
éviter le fait que les blancs vont
reprendre une tour au coup suivant les
termes de pièces pur ya égalité fou et 6
et ça y est il choisit de prendre là il
choisit de prendre la tour et fuit donc
il choisi car iachini si d'entrée dans
alors après il faut voir la suite mais
il choisit ici d'entrer dans une finale
où potentiellement on aura des
footballeurs opposée puisqu'il a pris
ici donc ce fucile repris après la passe
d'armes
alors on va voir ça tout de suite il
choisit d'abord d'un programme car c'est
moi il faut être précis pour prendre et
maintenant regarder pouf
voilà on reprend le fou avec la tour ce
qui fait qu'on n'est plus en prise et
voilà mais voilà faute de couleurs
opposées dont la carcel se retrouve dans
une finale où après le coup maintenant
fans de la tactique fou prend à 6 les
blancs gagne petit pion mais en foot que
le reposer et on l'a vu déjà dans les
parties précédentes puisque on a vu pas
mal de
deux cas on a vu déjà une finale
semblables dans le match où j'ai rappelé
le fait que les footeux leur poser sont
un facteur de très fort facteur annulant
en cas de finale et donc le relais il
reste les tours ce qui donne encore des
petites chances voilà donc petit
avantage quand même les genres
avantageux blanc mais on va voir c'est
quasiment rien puisque les noirs jouent
le simple b4 et ce pion là qui peut
défendue par le fou est inattaquable par
le foot est blanche et donc il domine
ses deux pions bon donc ce pion vos ses
deux pions là c'est impossible pour les
blancs d'envisager d'aller prendre un
mais quatre là suffit que le fou soit
sur recettes sur cette diagonale
c'est impossible on peut rien faire dès
qu'on pousse pour il ya prise en a trois
et donc on peut rien faire on est bloqué
ce pion vous bossez de l'art tout
simplement fou de couleurs opposées
finalement pu rien faire donc c'est pas
vraiment un problème dans ce type de
finale voyez de lâcher un pion très
souvent les foules opposées permettre
cette possibilité là donc arsène
tranquille sans problème pour c'est un
g6 tranquillou à la finale est normal
les banques peuvent rien faire en fait
pour ces 2 malgré la plainte plus tôt
ra8 attention le foot attaquer bon le
pion à deux derrière est protégé par la
tour ou des trois tours des 8es coup
deux des coûts d'amusement maintenant
parce qu'ils le savent tous les deux que
c'est fini fou de foot que leur opposer
la avec reina faire il n'y a pas deux
qui ont passé l'option b 4 domine
totalement et est imprenable à tout
moment fawcett mieux que vous ce étroite
attention parce que sur un fou c'est 3 à
3 et en cas de prise le fou est perdu et
ben voilà c'est pas top
donc il faut hausse est par contre en
cas de victoire mais surprendre puis on
prend et c'est les noirs qui sont mieux
ils ont une pure même qui est plus
proche de table que celui des blancs on
en n'est pas là il m'aime pas attaquer
les courbes et quatre en fuite
ouais enfin voilà on va on centralise
les rois tranquille tu auras huit bons à
3,8
on verrouille la casa trois ans pourrait
faire avec les blancs
dès qu'on pousse prise et la tour
protégeant plus ses quatre tours s'est
vite l'amusement des deux champions là
aux deux recettes f4 bon je ne peux
quand même h6 wave 3 tours c'est cette
île se passe rien moyens gkd bon les
blancs il s'est un peu avancé mais bon
ils peuvent rien faire parce que les
voilà les cases noires en verrouillant
ils n'ont pas moyens de forcer sur cases
noires il peut essayer de repousser un
peu l'adversaire mais sans plus quoi
j'essaierai que d'ailleurs les noirs se
met même en position défensive wallace à
dire qu'ils mettent leurs pions sur noir
en disant me coûte se passe rien à noter
que ces deux pions lassons pas mal parce
qu'ils restreignent le fou il joue
contre le fu blanc là il n'a pas de
diagonale intéressante
impossible d'aller attaquer f7 ne
pourrait pas attaqué et la tour ce
serait beaucoup trop compliqué c'est
impossible
donc c'est extrêmement solide et ça
empêche le fou de se balader mieux en
plus qu'à décharge des tours c'est nul
tout de suite le tour d'une micro
chances de possibilités mais pas dans
cette position rôle 4 et enfin tour
s'éviter les joueurs signent la partie
nulle après trente trois coups nouvelle
victoire aux points quand même dire un
psychologie de cars s'est noyé la pas
souffert dans cette partie du toit est
rien et là il a surpris un petit peu car
yakine avec le cook a blessé six ans et
vit un coup un peu rare bon mais sans
plus qu'à lever 4 voilà c'est qu'après
calais b 4 et avec la passe tactique qui
a suivi on voit assez vite qu'eux car ce
n était vraiment comme un poisson dans
l'eau
rocard in là ou non puis mais sur n'a
plus de problème ils avaient les blancs
donc avec les blancs championnat du
monde il faut quand même c'est créer des
problèmes sinon espérer gagner avec les
noirs face à carcelle ça va pas être
facile quand même parce que mon dieu qui
l'a prouvé avec les noirs on voit bien
qu'avec les blancs par contre s'il n'est
pas loin de la victoire donc on sent que
car ce n est pas loin de pouvoir marquer
un point mais attention on n'est jamais
à l'abri en championnat du monde
on l'a vu face à nantes bailleur un
quart scène a des ratés à un moment
donné un coup qui permettait à la norme
de prendre un avantage un coup simple il
avait fait une gaffe en fait et on en
aurait pu revenir dans le match mais
pour l'instant pas de gaffe du côté
carsen tout est nickel 1 depuis le début
donc nul avec les noirs maintenant il
reste cinq parties il va avoir trois
fois les blancs car c'est lui il est là
pour marquer s'il marque une fois
simplement sur le seigneur est reparti
trois fois les blogs il al'avantage ici
en termes de couleurs et dans ce cas là
il pourrait gagner ce lire rester avec
son titre mais pour l'instant il n'a pas
réussi à passer la memoria la muraille
car yakine le russe montre un très très
beau jeu aussi solide bon mais sans
poser de vrais problèmes norvégien mais
il faut attention parce qu'à pression
passant après les 12 premières parties
après le match tous partis c'est des
parties rapides et l'a en partie rapide
car ce n est pas du tout à l'abri d'une
gaffe qui permettrait à karim de devenir
et bien le alors le ca va faire le
le 17e champion du monde je crois bien
parce que je crois car donc kramnik
c'était 14
ensuite un an de 15 est effectivement
carsen doit être le 16e et donc ça fait
carradine sur les 17e bon regard n'est
pas là il est dominé un petit peu même
si le match est nul il a carsen aura
trois fois les blancs et on s'attend
voilà donc à ce point final voilà merci
de m'avoir suivi poursuivre cette
septième partie du match championnats du
monde 2016 entre magnus larsen le tenant
et si un cahier qui le challenger le
match reste très indécis rendez vous
pour la prochaine partie
au revoir